the ongoing feud between president trump
and andrew cuomo
is not getting any better president
trump warning he could cut federal
funding to democrat-run cities that have
seen months of rising violence and
unrest
and that includes new york city
washington d.c seattle
and portland new york governor cuomo
responding by appearing to threaten the
president
watch this look the best thing he did
for new york city
was leave
good riddance let them go to florida
be careful not to get covered kofit
ambushed new york
due to trump's negligence
he is the cause of covid in new york
changed his residence to go to florida
why he can't come back to new york
he can't he's gonna walk down the street
in new york
forget bodyguards he better have an army
if he thinks he's going to walk down the
street in new york
no new yorkers don't want to have
anything to do with them and he knows it
i much prefer the feud between cuomo and
de blasio
and actually that might get us somewhere
kennedy we have you back
and you are a new yorker as well uh your
thoughts about this
feud he's just trying to sound like a
tough guy and all he's doing
is cya because
cuomo really screwed up in terms of
covid all you have to do is look
at the 11 000 patients who died in
nursing homes
when he forced them to take sick
patients and it was a conflagration and
it was completely inhumane
he hasn't accepted responsibility for
that and it was a totally heartless move
so what he's trying to do is deflect
it's the same thing that that
ted wheeler does and kate brown and
oregon they're just trying to blame the
president
in order to skirt accountability because
as long as you're doing that
you don't have to actually do anything
and i challenge them
that the presidency is clearly way too
powerful of a position
and that is the result of years and
years of abdication
on the part of congress so if if one
person
is that powerful and can kill so many
people
then something is gravely wrong with our
political system
jessica what about you you also live in
new york and you've seen
you know what's unfolding there i mean
what do you think should happen
in some of these cities you know they
have been run by democrats for years do
does the president have a point i'm not
sure he has a point in so far as saying
that he's going to start withdrawing
funds from these cities but he certainly
does when he says that andrew cuomo is
responsible for the 11 000 deaths that
kennedy pointed out there and our own
janice dean lost both of her
in-laws her husband's parents both died
in nursing homes and
those outcomes could have been avoided
in new york and new jersey phil murphy
had the same policy they just
ended up losing less lives there um gone
are the days of andrew cuomo who's
thanking the president for the
ventilators remember that
or for saving sending the ship that we
were going to have tons of code patients
on and no one ever stepped on board
i think that there needs to be a
lowering of the temperature
we have to be realistic about what's
going on and there can be productive
discussions about
you know local state and federal
officials about how we can get kids back
to school safely we're already seeing
colleges having to send people home
so that's my top concern less ego more
fixing it
greg do you think that cuomo and de
blasio
just really want people like trump
and others to leave and go to florida or
elsewhere
well they need the people they hate
to uh for the tax base so it's a
short term it must feel great but then
again it's also like
rich white liberals who are leaving too
the kind of
the best people a socialist would want
they're fleeing as well
so anybody with money is getting out of
town i will congratulate cuomo on his
honesty about how
unsafe the new york streets are uh he
just admitted it
and i think murders are up 51 over past
august uh so i think that should get
cuomo on board
for indoor dining just to protect
citizens from the stray
bullets uh but i think to your point if
i had
if i had after the downtown looting
said to uh bill de blasio you know you
better have an
army if you come down here because i'm
pissed
i would probably be arrested because
that would be considered a threat
i just hope that uh chris chris and his
brother do a nice little comedy routine
tonight on cnn when they discuss this
and instead of a giant q-tip
they can have uh how about a torch to
help lead the mob when trump shows up
um those tough guys
viva la revolution revolution i guess i
should say
jesse what do you think about saying
that the president would need an
army to come and visit new york he kind
of actually does have
an army in the in the secret service
yeah the democratic party is now
officially the party of violence and
threats it started when they firebombed
the limousine at inauguration and they
haven't looked back since
de niro says he wants to punch trump out
biden says he wants to punch him out
loretta lynch says she wants to see
blood in the streets eric holder said
kick him you have antifa pulling people
out of trucks
kicking them in the head shooting them
in the head bernie bro
shot steve scalise they're swarming and
attacking trump supporters
while they're leaving speeches they're
doxing you they're
surrounding your house i mean has
anybody been paying attention to what's
been said by the celebrities madonna
wants to blow up the white house
johnny depp and snoop dogg talk about
assassinating the president
we're just going to pretend like that
didn't happen
i mean the guy has been under fire
constantly
and then the left says he's the one
fanning the flames
and then they ignore all the video that
shows them
fanning said flames what they've done
is they've said he's a white supremacist
he's hitler and that justifies
all the destruction of action that
they've taken
but i think it's going to blow up in
their face november 3rd and
by the way i caught greg calling for
another call for in someone else's block
i'm watching
you keep you keep a track over there in
your little pod all right